hello everyone and welcome back to the
other clash that we've been waiting for
it's the second game
between gary kasparov and vishwanathan
and we've already seen that
the clash between the two of them in
yesterday's match
and it was a pretty nice one that
kasparov lost on time in in worse
position but now kasparov has the white
pieces and he has a chance to bounce
back
and yesterday we've said that um you
know kasparov has quite a nice lead
against anand in pretty much
in all time formats and anand was able
to lower the lead yesterday a little bit
so now anan gets the chance to lower it
even further today so let's see what
happens it's kasparov with the white
pieces today
uh let's see uh how the game went so
kasparov with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh anand replies with
knight to f6 we have c4 e6 and the
knight the c3 we have bishop to b4
knight to f3 and d5 we basically
transposed into our goes in defense
of the queen's gambit declined we have c
captures on d5e captures and now bishop
to f4 by kasparov
we have c6 by anand and the queen to c2
now so nicely developing the queen
and because kasparov developed the queen
so nicely on and takes uh
use of this and plays g6 now he wants to
play bishop to f5 to develop his bishop
with
tempo attacking the white queen so e3
and now bishop to f5 attacking
kasparov's queen we have queen to b3
and now as the bishop is attacked you
could capture the knight here which
isn't
really a something you want to do you
could bring the bishop back but then you
expose the b7 pawn
so of course you just bring the queen
over to b6 uh we have knights to h4
taking advantage now of the weirdly
placed bishop so bishop back to e6
and now uh continuing development bishop
to d3
now anand also wants to take advantage
of kasparov is a weirdly placed bishop
so he plays
knights the h5 attacking the bishop here
so bishop to e5 attacking ghanan's rook
and here are
unjust castles and uh here casparo went
into
a deep thing well it was about a minute
and something but still it's a lot
since it's a five minute game and he
decided to play g4 and at the moment he
played the g4 it's a very nice pawn
sacrifice
he was already down to one minute
whereas anand uh had
some four and a half minutes left and
it's not a new move it has been played
before but only in one game
and in that game black replied with
knights to g7 which is good for white
but here anand accepts the challenge he
just captures the pawn
and he says okay gary what do you got
here let's let's see the moves
uh and of course gary starts the attack
rook the g1
so now uh the rook is eyeing here uh the
the king along the
basically x-raying the king along the g
file the bishops here
are very nicely placed he's probably
going to bring the queen to c2 and put
a lot of pressure here on the black's
king side so here we have bishop back to
e6 as
anand's bishop is under attack and now
queen to c2 and now you can see that uh
four of kasparov's pieces are attacking
that
g6 pawn but uh on and here he uh here is
the
first time anand basically spent some
time in the game he was calculating if
everything is okay if he has a defense
against all the sacrifices gary was
going to throw at him
and he said yes there is no problem i'm
just going to continue
development knight to d7 and it also
comes with an attack on
one of kasparov's very strong attacking
pieces and that is the bishop on e5
so here kasparov has to act he's very
low on the clock and he goes forward he
plays bishop captures on g6
and okay there's no uh other move you
have to capture this bishop and you have
to capture it with the f pawn so f
captures in g6
uh we have knight captures and g6 and
now this knight cannot be captured if
you capture it
then you are getting checkmated queen
captures here knight blocks
and then queen captures and g7 will be
checkmate however
uh anand calculated all of this so after
knight captures on g6 he just plays
knight captures an e5 now he gives up
the rook
but it's not a problem a rook for two
pieces is is always great if you're not
getting checkmated
so here we have knight captures on f8
king captures an f8 and now
kasparov has to waste the move to to
capture back some material here
so d captures on e5 and now comes queen
to c7
uh uh getting the queen back into the
defense not allowing something like
queen captures on uh h7 and here
kasparov plays
f4 you have to start advancing those
pawns if you can get these pawns off the
board
uh good things might happen and the
problem is kasparov is down to
15 seconds on the clock and anand has
about a minute and a half
so here queen to f7 anand brings the
queen
over here to help out with the defense
of the f5 square so kasparov can start
pushing those pawns
and now because part of castle's queen
side now he wants to play rook to f1 and
then
continue with his plan so bishop to f5
of course anand will not allow this we
have queen to be three now attacking the
bishop
and now even a5 not even rushing with
bishop captures on c3 anand feels very
comfortable in his position and he just
solidifies his position with a5 and
later on he can
continue pushing his pawns on the queen
side if he decides so if not then he can
just
you know try and re-maneuver the rook
into the game like this
uh you know keep the king safe and
everything is fine for him
so here knight to e2 now kasparov wants
to uh
get this knight to d4 and then gain
control of these squares but now comes
knight to g7 and here uh uh the the
knight is now
coming into the game uh also via the e6
square
because power brings the knights to d4
and here and has to be
well he has to be very very precise here
he has to play
either bishop to e4 or he can bring the
rook into the game he can
start by something like b6 and then
advance maybe to c5
but he plays bishop the c5 uh which uh
is
uh he's getting ready to start the
attack over on kasparov's queen side
but this allows kasparov a very dirty
trick to get back into the game
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this nasty trick while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
rook captures on g7 that's the good
stuff we
we have to capture now uh with the king
if we don't then
the queen leaves the defense of the
bishop here on f5 so king captures
but now it doesn't matter we still
capture an f5 and now we want to get the
queen away from the defense of the
pawn on b7 and if queen captures queen
captures on b7 check
now we pick up the rookie and if the
king goes to the sixth rank we can even
pick up the pawn with check and then
pick up the rook and a8
however uh both of them extremely low on
time gary uh
even more so after bishop to c5 he did
not play
uh rook captures on g7 because paul
played rook to g3
but now aaron can the simply start
eliminating some of the pressure bishop
captures on d4 was played
we have e capture sunday for by kasparov
but as he played e captures on d4
uh it was in this position that
kasparov's time ran out
and uh well he was in this position that
kasparov lost the game
so much like in the in the first game
they played in this tournament uh
it was a better position for anand and
kasparov was trying something so here
kasparov has a rook for two pieces
which is uh sometimes good here not
really because it's very hard to create
some sort of an attack against black's
king for example
anand can just start uh you know getting
his king to safety
bring the rook over into the game and
even if rook d the g1 trying to make use
of the g
file we can just play bishop to g6 and
we have full control of the f5 square
it's not a problem the queen guards the
b7 pawn so
uh it would be it could be an
interesting game but of course
black black is still much better here uh
so
after e captures on d4 kasparov lost on
time and
anand takes a second win in this
tournament against his former rival gary
kasparov
and you know continues to have a very
nice tournament
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank robert
arthur
and jim uh alboy cruzad.com and
christopher machete for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the mini
kasparov saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day